did you ever share a spot of tea um
because i love i've had wine with kevin
hart
and i know that you are making die hard
together and i
love this whole concept of this show so
like
have you ever had tea with him um well
like on set he um do you know what i
he actually introduced introduced me to
some tea
he would send someone to get a specific
tea every day
and it was like peach and like mint or
peppermint and
peach tea thing and um and i was like
kevin hart drink so fruity like
but it was great because it was like
really good it kind of cleared your sort
of
airways and your sinuses and it was
great like
especially when you're on and we were
filming in atlanta and it was quite cold
and quite
um like wet and
damp at the time so in a kind of
like slightly sweet kind of
aromatic tea was quite good um but he
liked to tease me because i always had
my my little eco cup thing
with different teasing you'll be like oh
are you drinking tea you know like
because i always
always had that cup i know but it's not
just that tea tastes good like it's
really healing like it's medicine
and in some forms like elderberry or
echinacea like there's so many
things like that you know silver needle
like all these things are like really
good for you
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going